[Music]
foreign
focusing on the fact that Hollywood
constantly churns out woke propaganda
pieces disguised as Cinema and that's of
course true
and a large part of the reason why
audiences are losing interest in movies
this past Thanksgiving box office tally
a time when theaters typically rake in
massive amounts of money saw the weakest
performance in over 25 years this in
spite of the fact that there or maybe
because of the fact there were multiple
sequels to Blockbuster franchise films
showing uh there was a new Steven
Spielberg movie there was a Disney
cartoon about a gay teenage boy and a
disabled dog
you know all these things were at
theater and uh nobody went like I said
wokeness is certainly part of the
problem here but not the whole problem
because the other issue is that so many
movies are boring and dull and simply
not anything to get excited about
and it seems that the people involved in
making these cinematic versions of bland
stale graham crackers are aware at some
level of how boring and uninteresting it
all is and that's why they have to go to
increasingly desperate lengths to
pretend that their films are somehow
revolutionary and provocative even as
they serve up the same under seasoned
dish that we've had a million times
before
and I think that's part of what was
happening this week when Jennifer
Lawrence now uh somewhat infamously sat
down for an interview with variety and
ended up claiming a title for herself
that
people older than 10 years old might
find surprising as it doesn't quite gel
with our memories
Lawrence declared that she is the first
actress to have ever starred in a
Hollywood action film now Jennifer
Lawrence is 32 okay she's not in her 70s
or 80s which she would have to be in
order for that claim to have any chance
of legitimacy but uh let's watch the
clip first
I remember when I was doing Hunger Games
nobody had ever put a woman in the lead
of an action movie because it wouldn't
work we were told girls and boys can
both identify with a male lead but boys
cannot identify with a female lead oh
absolutely and it just makes me so happy
every single time I see a movie come out
that just blows through every single one
of those beliefs and proves
that it is just a lie to keep certain
people out of the movies to keep certain
people in the same positions that
they've always been in and it's just
amazing to watch it happen and watch you
at the helmet
yes the Hunger Games released in 2012
was the that was the the first action
film with a female lead Lawrence then
noted that it was also a great honor to
co-star in the Silver Linings Playbook
so that she could get a front row seat
to Robert De Niro's first film role and
she's especially humbled to realize that
when she played Mystique in X-Men first
Class she was starring in the first
superhero movie ever made truly an
historic career in her own mind if not
in reality because in reality of course
Sigourney Weaver exists Linda Hamilton
exists Angelina Jolie exists there have
been many female action Stars over the
decades going back to Carrie Fisher in
Star Wars even before her there were
others
um Jennifer Lawrence is not the first to
do anything
nor the best
she didn't even come up with like a new
way of doing something she just followed
a script that had long since been
written trying to pretend that she's
breaking glass ceilings that have been
laying in shards on the ground for
decades
glass ceilings that in this case we
should note never mattered much to begin
with
okay the fact that there are more men
starring in action films than women who
cares it makes sense that most action
stars are men as men typically make more
compelling and believable action Stars
typically okay it's a lot harder to make
a female action here into anything but a
silly cartoon Sigourney Weaver pulled it
off which is why her performance is
still remembered by everyone except
Jennifer Lawrence apparently and yet
more often it ends up being a kind of
goofy girl power routine
men can can also see a man it's easier
for a male actor to elevate goofy action
plots and lend them a certain gravitas
Batman is an absolutely ridiculous
concept okay it is it's just absurd you
gotta guide dresses up in a rubber
costume as a bat running around it's
it's ridiculous and yet every man in the
role except maybe George Clooney has
pulled it off with varying degrees of
success meanwhile there's never been a
bat girl that was anything but cringe on
steroids
because men are more natural for these
roles and and generally generally
speaking they're just better at them
don't be distracted by parties and
presents this holiday season instead
join Hallows most anticipated prayer
challenge of the Year pray 25 led by
cast members from The Chosen the largest
Christian streaming Series in history
Prague 25 will guide you through
meditation and prayer for 25 days
leading up to Christmas pray 25 will
help grow your understanding of mankind
develop a disciplined prayer habit
during a season when discipline is put
to the test hello is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S and the
number one Catholic app in the world
hello helps me make prayer a priority
and with pray 25 it can do the same for
you find peace and fortify your faith
this Christmas season with hallow
download the app for free and join the
pray 25 challenge go to hello.com Matt
Walsh and get three months completely
free that's hello.com Matt Walsh to
reclaim your peace during this holiday
season
um all that to say
there was never a problem of Too Many
Men acting in action films there were
there were more men than women acting in
them um up until recently now because
now you can't have a you know a white
male lead for anything
but that's not a problem it wasn't a
problem
any more than there was ever a problem
of of there being too many men who are
roofers you know you notice that the
feminists are always very selective
about the professions where they demand
representation
I think I've seen maybe one female in my
life riding on the back of a trash truck
through the neighborhood
somehow though there's no National
discourse about the representation
problem in the waste disposal industry
so it's okay
for gender disparities to exist in
certain contexts for feminists
but in reality it's just yeah it is it's
okay in general it's a gender
disparities are natural
because men and women are different
and they gravitate towards different
things and they have and they have
aptitudes in different things in
different areas uh women are better in
certain areas generally men are better
in certain areas generally that's just
that's just that that's that's the
nature of uh that's human nature
it's the attempt to artificially even
everything out
that tends to always cause more problems
than it solves
but this is somewhat immaterial because
the point here is that Jennifer Lawrence
came along after females had already
made their entrance into the action film
genre she's trying to recycle
Progressive victories from a generation
before her and we've seen this similar
charade with uh we see this all the time
with the left but we've seen it in Holly
we've seen with other movies such as
when Black Panther was celebrated as
some kind of breakthrough because it was
a film with a mostly Black cast even
though such films have been made by
Hollywood for years for decades
there have been black superheroes before
as well we had them in the 90s
so black panther didn't Pioneer anything
Ross douthit made this point in his book
decadent society which he quoted in
response to Jennifer Lawrence's flub and
reading from the passage is what he says
the reality of recurrence may be
slightly harder for progressives to
acknowledge than conservatives because
progressivism is more invested in its
supposed position at the Vanguard of
cultural change pressing boldly on to
New Frontiers this makes it difficult
for the left to recognize the
generational recycling of its Ambitions
and anxieties the fact that many
Progressive breakthroughs are just the
cultural cycling the culture cycling
back to something that we did not that
long ago up to and including Kick-Ass
female action heroes such as Wonder
Woman who followed a path Blaze by
Sigourney Weaver's Ripley in the alien
movies or the robot wrangling Sarah
Connor and the Terminator movies or even
the Blaster wielding Princess Leia in
the Star Wars 40 years before that or
the African-American heroes in Black
Panther in truth black stars were
arguably more important in the years of
Eddie Murphy and Richard Pryor in The
Cosby Show and The Young Denzel
Washington then in our officially
representation obsessed age
now his book decadent Society is about
as you may have guessed decadence we are
a decadent Society in the sense that we
as doubt that has it are locked in this
kind of cultural stalemate Treading
Water adrift board recycling the same
ideas and themes
now I don't agree with all of his thesis
but when it comes to our artistic output
there is no question about it
a decadent Society
with decadent celebrities clamoring to
be cultural revolutionaries
in a culture that they have already won
they already own it
and that ultimately is why Jennifer
Lawrence is today Cancer
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or have listened to the full show
head to dailywire.com And subscribe
today you can also listen to my podcast
on Spotify Apple podcast or wherever you
get your podcasts